[Applause]
ryan gosling chris evans pulse-pounding
twists and turns and an action-packed
ending what else could we ask for in a
movie from character motivations to
themes to hints at a sequel we're here
to explain the ending of the gray man
warning major spoilers ahead
when we first meet six he's just a young
man named cortland gentry doing jail
time in florida state prison for
murdering his abusive father when he was
15. he isn't eligible for parole until
2031 but a member of the cia named
donald fitzroy gives him the chance to
walk out of prison for good if he kills
bad guys on behalf of the agency's
sierra program portland agrees we
rejoined cortland 18 years later he no
longer has a name instead going by the
number six his job is to exist in the
gray zones of life this means he isn't
exactly an individual he's more of a
tool of the united states government
used to carry out covert operations they
would rather have the public know
nothing about like assassinations it's a
dangerous life naturally but six takes
everything in stride he's not a
particularly emotional man and is
entirely matter of fact about his work
how is he able to put his life on the
line without having a nervous breakdown
beats being on the wrong side of the
bars even though his life as an assassin
is beyond difficult at least he's not
stuck in a jail cell being punished for
a justifiable murder
instead he gets to protect people just
like he protected his little brother
from the hands of their monstrous father
we learn exactly what kind of man danny
carmichael is from the moment he orders
six to take out a target regardless of
the fact that a child will be hurt in
the process this is someone who demands
his orders be followed without question
and likes to keep his secrets buried six
feet underground the details aren't
completely clear but we also learn that
he forced this way into his current
position sending fitzroy into an early
retirement carmichael's goal is to run
things his way which includes performing
unsanctioned assassinations with private
hitmen rather than agents employed by
the us government the mission that opens
the movie sees six kill four another
sierra agent because he's selling
information to america's enemies that
documents carmichael's corrupt
activities 6 takes the encrypted drive
that contains this information and mails
it to an ally named margaret cahill once
decoded the drive reveals carmichael's
attempts to eliminate the cia as it
currently exists and rebuild it on his
own terms it's his corruption that makes
six go rogue although he never
explicitly says it in the film all of
his decisions reveal that he does what
he does because it's the right thing to
do learning that the new people in
charge are only interested in protecting
themselves motivates him to step out of
the grave for the first time in 18 years
and start doing things his way
in a flashback set two years before the
events of the film fitzroy's address is
leaked online this is a major problem
the nature of his job means he has a lot
of enemies who won't hesitate to murder
him or his niece claire whom he's raised
since the death of her parents denny
carmichael will not provide them with a
security team so fitzroy and cahill turn
to six for assistance all six has to do
is keep claire alive from what we know
about six at this point we can tell he
approaches each job with a motionless
precision that's exactly how he starts
off his babysitting gig but claire was
born with a heart condition and needs a
pacemaker when it malfunctions we see a
subtle change in the grey man's demeanor
he isn't just looking after claire
because he has to he actually cares
about her after she's released from the
hospital claire mentions that fitzroy is
the only family she has left six says
fitzroy is the closest thing he has to
family at all claire wonders if that
makes them family in some way given the
fact that six killed his own father to
protect himself and his brother and the
passion with which he takes on a horde
of professional killers to keep claire
safe it seems he truly does consider her
to be family
carmichael's information exists on an
encrypted drive that's hidden inside of
a medallion when sierra iv gives six the
drive he asks him to use it to take
carmichael down carmichael understands
that six knows how to disappear and is
carrying intel that could end his career
and get him locked up for the rest of
his life so he turns to a killer named
lloyd hanson to make sure six dies as
quickly as possible essentially hanson
is everything six isn't while six is a
measured and calculated person hansen is
loud emotional and reckless he flaunts
his wealth relishes torturing people and
hates cats carmichael seeks his help
because they were buddies at harvard and
he knows hansen will do whatever it
takes to get the job done if that means
killing loads of innocent civilians well
so be it as is so often the case with
heroes and villains six and hansen are
twisted mirror images of each other both
men kill for a living and do so with
relative ease both are relentless in
pursuit of their goals anson even says
he thinks he and six could have been
friends there's one major difference
though six does his job because it's
right hanson in contrast does it for
kicks and the boatloads of money it
makes him there's no gray area when it
comes to hansen he is evil and chris
evans plays him as such
danny miranda's first words in the gray
man are said in bangkok do you need
anything although she doesn't know it
yet this sets up the fact that she will
be six's ally for the rest of the film
to her this is just another job for the
cia when things go sideways and six
takes matters into his own hands however
she's forced to make a pivotal choice
miranda is exceptionally professional
but there's a part of her that knows
something is deeply wrong with the cia
yet she takes their abuse and follows
orders until median six wakes her up by
all accounts when six goes on the run
she should step away and let carmichael
do his job but she chooses to help six
just like she chooses to ignore a
dismissal from other agents following
the murder of sierra iv after saving six
from lloyd hanson she tells him that his
actions have had a negative impact on
her career because it made carmichael
think she and six plan to steal the
information but when six points out that
the cia has been killing its own agent
since she might be next she decides to
help him find out what's on the
encrypted drive seeing that carmichael
has been carrying out unsanctioned hits
she officially aligns herself with six
to take carmichael down this is more
important than her career
once lloyd hansen is hired to find the
drive and kill six he determines the
most effective way of doing so is by
going after donald fitzroy as the film
firmly establishes fitzroy is basically
the father six never had which makes him
the only person six truly trusts
assuming fitzroy will have information
on six's whereabouts anson kidnaps his
niece claire and threatens to kill her
fitzroy orders the team to kill six to
protect claire but he survives just as
fitzroy knows he will he tells his
honorary son about claire's capture and
from that moment on six isn't as
concerned with surviving as he is with
saving clear we see in flashbacks that
the abused sick suffered at his father's
hands numbed him to pain this was the
old man's intent he believed that
ignoring pain would make sick succeed in
life while it's certainly true that pain
doesn't seem to bother six he can't sit
by and allow innocent people to
experience it he protected his little
brother in 1995 and now his little
sister needs his help every decision he
makes from here on out is to get to
claire
this is his new mission and he'll do
anything go anywhere and kill anyone to
carry it out successfully
when six babysits clear she notices his
tattoo since she's incredibly
inquisitive she asks him a bunch of
questions about its meaning he explains
that it's a man's name in greek this
particular man was condemned by the gods
to push a rock up a hill for all
eternity if you're familiar with greek
mythology you will probably have already
picked up on the fact that he's talking
about sisyphus sisyphus was a trickster
king who cheated death not once but
twice his fruitless boulder rolling was
his punishment as dictated by zeus
claire asks 6 if sisyphus liked pushing
the rock a pill and 6 tells her he
probably didn't then she asks if he ever
made it to the top of the hill six's
response is perfect
i'll let you know this conversation
particularly six's final answer suggests
that six identifies with sisyphus in
fact you can see the entire film as a
sisyphus-like story did sisyphus really
deserve damnation for wanting to prolong
his own life does cortland gentry really
deserve to go to prison for wanting to
keep himself and his brother alive the
grey man suggests that the answer is no
fitzroy even says he would have done the
same thing in courtland's shoes
therefore six's life as a cia agent is
his version of pushing a rock up a hill
it's an eternal punishment for a
justifiable crime
there are three major antagonists in the
grey man the first two are fairly
obvious danny carmichael is the
villainous ringleader who sends forth a
horde of minions to do his dirty work
lloyd hansen is his wild unpredictable
and borderline rabbit hound who chases
everything in sight but the third
antagonist isn't revealed until the
climax of the third act even though
she's been there the whole time she's
suzanne brewer for most of the film
brewer who is yet another cia agent
appears to be a cool head in a hot
situation she contradicts nearly every
call carmichael makes and never
hesitates to point out people's nonsense
in the end when hanson or six are
fighting to the death she ends hansen's
life it seems as though she intends to
help six but in truth she has her own
plans brewer intends for hansen to take
the fall for everything that's happened
it will look like he stole the
information himself in the hopes of
using it for his own gain all she needs
to achieve this is for six miranda and
carmichael to corroborate her story they
do and everything goes off without a
hitch the drive is even destroyed to
make sure the information never gets out
the one mistake she makes however is
keeping claire as a hostage so she can
control six
hanson puts a hit on six that's so big
every professional killer in the world
wants to end him yet even in this crowd
bounty hunter avik son manages to stand
out he shows up after a car chase in a
public area which results in millions of
dollars worth of damage worse six gets
away when avik arrives he becomes
hansen's last hope avik is as good at
his job as six and hansen are at theirs
he hunts miranda in six with the patient
tenacity of a terminator he cannot be
stopped and payne doesn't get in his way
in this he and six are very similar
honor also ties them together when
miranda and six storm the croatian
headquarters where hanson has claire and
fitzroy avik gives up the fight he lets
miranda have the encrypted drive and
says he doesn't care about the money
anymore because he's learned hansen's
team has no honor this in essence is the
film's theme honor vs dishonor or good
guys versus bad guys several times
targets are referred to as bad guys even
when they might not be all bad it all
boils down to motivation hanson kills
for pleasure carmichael kills for power
brewer kills for influence six and
miranda killed to protect people and
fitzroy kills to save his niece a
dichotomy is clear between those who
kill selflessly and those who kill
selfishly this is the film's
understanding of good and evil
hansen is killed and blamed for the
events of the film miranda's position
with the cia is restored but she might
be planning something else carmichael
destroys the drive and retains his
position six is put in custody brewer is
pretty confident that because she has
claire she can make six do whatever she
wants unfortunately for her six still
has a mission protect claire at all
costs several characters in the grey man
revert to things going wrong as getting
loud these are people who are supposed
to operate in the hushed shadows
unnoticed by the rest of the world
drawing attention as happens when
someone or something produces a loud
noise is the worst thing they can do but
cortland gentry is done being quiet the
cia is corrupt and he's not going to
work on its behalf any longer instead
he's going to cast aside a sis of his
rock and take his life into his own
hands how do we know he's going to do
this he escapes from the hospital kills
everyone he encounters and tracks down
claire she finds a note from him telling
her to play a record loud this blocks
out the sounds of violence just outside
her door but it also signifies six's
intentions the time to be quiet is over
if there's a sequel we might see how
loud cortland gentry can really get now
that he finally has his family and his
freedom
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]